hello went welcome to this video this is
coverage for round three of the
candidates tournament the UM third round
is last round before the day off Monday
March 14th will be a rest day so I think
it's a or the more or the more what that
kind of English is that yeah there's
even more reason for people to try to
find maybe get their first to win in
let's see what happened today I have to
say that my overview maybe is not as
deep as it usually is i have to tell you
that i played the game myself today and
the german leak and it was a it was um
it was not a super tiring game but still
yeah you play for far four hours you
drive two hours to the plate and so I'm
pretty pretty tired and I had to limit
myself a little bit and looking through
the games anyway I think it would be a
good overview of what happened today
let's start with the game and kawana and
yeah we all can complain or whatnot but
keep playing this opening and well as
often said I understand why but I don't
have to like it ok iono goes for d3
which is usually leading to the most
interesting um games out of this opening
and Bishop c5 see three castles councils
d6 so far so good um we had this
position earlier in the event where
night BTW to was played also by island
when he played too pal off then 97 was
played before and so on a difference is
that here black was able to play the
move Bishop g4 but now Allen goes h3
investor tempo to prevent the bishop
coming to pin the noid p yeah 97 anyway
d4 and Bishop to b6 this is a difference
to the positions we saw earlier for
example in the tunnel to part of game
where black can taken and then we treat
it
this is now not played when black is
going back here the difference is that
now we can afford that because II form
is also unprotected so if why it takes
on e5 black and recapture and so take
here or take it immediately this is
hanging yarn I'd be too was protecting
this pawn okay but wyd now goes Bishop
d3 looks like move the same piece twice
but you have to do something about the
center and now it is securely protected
now at six that was one idea of 97
rookie won rookie eight Quincy to white
is lending more support um for the e4
pawn yeah and now an interesting
decision by caruana he definitely has a
choice here what to do a condom yeah
play a normal-looking of c6 for example
or Bishop to b6 but he goes for
something I feel rather non-typical but
interesting he took on d4 and pawn takes
and now played the move c5 that's a very
interesting decision on the idea is that
right now is forced to yeah make some
kind of commitment in the center after
c5 I don't decided to capture that pawn
which is the yeah let's let's call it
keep it simple method and there were
more interesting tries at this let's say
more complex tries a 50 d fire white can
go d5 style of the Benoni it's a really
funny looking normally with that bishop
here but that's not necessarily so bad
and sometimes can play Bishop f5 or it
can go to a 5 and attacking this play
maybe a 6b five m wide also head 'if
I've which is interesting black probably
goes 95 and intends that it's an
entirely different the kind of position
but this isn't bad for what an
interesting alternative yeah and said
this is the keep it simple method
the idea is that after the following
Moosa and I think those are really quite
quite logically we have some trades you
have centralization so why did Alan take
on c5 because the end for this type of
position Black has said somewhat weak
looking the six point on a half-open
file that can be pressurized and black
really doesn't have much to show for
that so why it is a little bit better
definitely but it is just one weakness
and very often one weakness can be
easily defended we shouldn't forget that
black also has some sunglasses he can
use the dark square CA like g5 at e 5
and in general others had one weakness
it's not so bad 23 that a porn was
cupboard rookie for shoot 7 and with t1
yeah on looking very normal yeah koala
is regrouping putting one Bishop you
know to see six to have some pressure
against the pawn and to utilize this
rookie six yeah black is covering d6
with with all his might and it looks a
tad passive but I don't think it's so
bad Bishop g2 now what is intending now
to push with f4 if allowed and koala is
some playing and defending this actively
you place the move h4 um dance I decided
to take it there also what's the move
effort that needed to be considered and
to be perfectly honest I'm not totally
sure if there's something wrong with it
yeah let's say a for Queen maybe to c5
and then the move g-form that's an
interesting try however Bishop takes e4
as possible funny funny little tactic
yeah white needs to be and care for him
to not yeah over expand him um yeah
maybe before first is necessary and then
white can see how I continues f5 maybe
it was possible but Alan solution is
simpler he just took on h4 it's probably
the simpler muth group d too late now
yeah more pressure on the e4 pawn and
yeah if there is some kind of way for
white to gaff to get something sustained
substantial it has to be found around
here the way it turned out I mean it
right has a couple of ideas you can yeah
we can play for a for still young let's
say feel go and for immediately there's
green c5 so maybe what about now I can
try before maybe controlling this and
then maybe try to expand further it's a
bit it's a bit risky but it's a way I
mean what he thought he plays is I think
probably not not aggressive enough a5
secures the c5 square and now after a
four black get set square and I think
probably White's hopes for something
substantial are almost over now blacks
counterplay is pretty good if or is
something that you can attack and that
queen is pretty strong get in the game
we relatively quickly go to a situation
where those pawns were traded and here
they agreed to a draw after move 40 um I
think that's somewhere somewhere around
here probably white has chances to
improve here not quite sure maybe
something like before but as I said I
couldn't invest lots of time here to to
make to make a very clear suggestion i'm
just very positive that after that was
played here that a 425 that from here it
will be very difficult to do to do
something for what he's got that pawn
that's all nice and good but it's a
double pawn and rather beak and black
skull to play against before is pretty
clear quite often they will just be a
trade-off between those two pawns and as
we had in the game and then nothing much
happened so um draw in this game i think
certainly an okay result for honor to
still sitting comfortably with this plus
one score caruana i'm not mistaken as
plate three fighting draws ok let's look
at the next game now yeah next game to
check is giri giri kayaking come on ok
let's see what we get here queens in
yeah yeah s'okay i can now place the
Queen's ended with black one of his main
openings all over or for the whole of
his chest Korea it was funny to see that
yesterday is called win with wide
against Nakamura or rather Nakamura um
kind of committed suicide in a slightly
worse position well we will actually get
a very similar position today in this
game g3 bush recession check back t5
it's quite funny with black now kayaking
is playing in the same style of yeah of
knockin Boris and we do we have the same
position it could be the same position
right it looks very very similar night
PG 70 rook e8 is probably the rookie 895
yeah this is I guess almost the gamer
the Nakamura kayaking Nakamura game
almost almost but I think my camera
playing a quicker night BTW
nine evade yeah we have the same kind of
static outline here Bishop e7 Bishop see
one that Bishop is regrouping and the
strategic outline is that black at some
point um has to do something with a see
porn um in the kayaking with white hemp
kayak in a camera game of round two neck
and where eventually played the move c5
you played 98 96 and then played c5
callicoon now goes for an entirely
different strategy he plays Bishop t 693
and now instead of going for some c5 he
plays the move a 5 it's important to see
that c5 here for example um can we need
to impound setup really rather
vulnerable vulnerable why it takes for
example Luke see one black is always has
to be on the lookout for night a for
Bishop e3 and so on those porns arm yeah
more like a target he played a 5 not
committing with the C porn just yet look
see one now night to be five is
certainly looming so c6 so this is not
the most active approach ever but it's
certainly quite solid it asks white very
very young kind of yeah a tricky
question yeah what are you going to do
what is white going to do it's not that
easy actually on the seafoam black has
some yeah put up a purely defensive
position difficult to do anything so um
what should do I do probably some break
in the center would be in order give me
place it in a very very slow way slow
with normal way let's say
you can also think about more violent
approaches for example if why try some
f3a are just brutally going for you for
then black will probably strike with c5
and why it is not so easily getting in a
for this is actually probably leading to
a rather sharp position f three years I
think a questionable idea i think what
QE does it's rather normally place that
a form see that c5 is not not coming and
now III here III rookie one yeah slowly
trying to improve the position Bishop a
six good move activating the bushing
rookie one yeah and now a very
interesting plan by kya can not at all
and yeah playing passively you could
think that this is a somewhat passive
position for black but he finds an
interesting activate Diego's h5 and this
is not a logical at all if you look at
this position white has a couple of
pieces yeah on the queenside or I'd say
rather far away from the king so why not
try to do something here on the kingside
we should h3 now interesting move and
now Neji for very enterprising play no
that is ultimately a pawn sacrifice
neither for taking this and black and
cause g6 now wide wins upon so kayaking
net sacrificed a pawn here for what
exactly well Black has got if we put
this on the board here and evaluate now
Black is got the two bishops the bishop
on a six is a pretty good piece yeah
it's rather active here on a six and
black maybe long-term has key in g7 rook
H
business on the edge foul so there is
some compensation the question is what
to do now for white um okay the Queen
can think I went to number of squares
f3s maybe the mayor taunted 3g5 was
played but if we look at every year for
example black my to here and then bomb
its compensation the game continues in a
very complicated way yeah Quincy five
was played and no Bishop to e7 attending
the discovery sim yeah and now I'm
giving um yeah opts for a very practical
decision in a way um he sacrifices on g6
after that move he has the draw in hand
with a repetition or perpetual check and
he can check if he finds more it's a
cautious decision in a way no it sounds
a wee idea why does mean sacrificing a
piece but I think it's very cautious in
a way because you have the drawing hand
you can look if you find something
better and if you don't you still have
the draw yeah so takes takes that
happened King age 8 and 95 now a funny
move yeah here in this position after
King edge aid and there were a couple of
interesting possibilities but ultimately
probably not something that leads to
more than the draw right can check for
example again here back and here in this
position I looked a bit at the movie for
something that intrigued me if black
takes with the night then why just wins
yeah Luke takes yes we have this threat
and after takes d5 this is deadly
absolutely deadly so um what about
context yeah this is not working check
this
this and now White has the pretty
remarkable move Knight takes b6 Queen TX
and rooks e5 let's preview pretty nice
the rook intends to come over here and
if black takes this is winning for what
or this is a bit stronger with me to
come and if I was a very dangerous move
but black hats Bishop before this is the
only move but it's probably also
sufficient white can shoot 45b should be
one and it takes a six and what is a
rook down but it's got three pawns and
he's got in tech but it seems to be not
more than the draw groups in seven here
and white now can can force a draw and
stuff like that yeah there's this move
also in the mix it should be six check
and against white can't go for a number
of checks here yeah I nls as I said a
little bit but it never really net
netted more than you draw and
interesting however he reformed probably
was a tougher try at ya setting problems
while keeping the draw in hand give me
tried night to c5 looking nice but after
this this white still only has the
firepower for a draw who gave aid was
played check and check know the end got
the draw here by perpetual check so I
draw here between geary and kayaking
kayaking certainly is okay with that i
guess he has his win in the back from
round two giri is on three drawers um
dan maybe he could have been a bit more
tricky here yeah with with the other
continuation sort of 95 going for that
idea with e4 but maybe ultimately that
night x 26 move only
let you draw yeah not a bad game but so
some games just end in drawers and they
don't necessarily have to be boring and
i think it was fairly very interesting
but it done yeah it was not it was not
enough okay um on the next game to check
and I have to find that in my notes just
a moment it's Nakamura swidler yeah and
this is actually the game where I feel
um I would have gotten to some clearer
conclusions if I had more time and gas
simply a little bit more a little bit
more stamina more power left for today I
would get to some more conclusions or
better conclusions we have a sloth and
I'm surprised that swidler is getting
this on the board for the second time
you already had that against kayaking in
round one and I'm surprised that
actually 93 again was played and naughty
III which is considered more profits
more popular nowadays on the top level
the same line as in round one and we
have that I QP position because Nakamura
now takes with the pawn which is far
more ambitious and I think also better
than 90 XD form or pay I can plate
Bishop is seven Queenie two castles and
black cannot take this poem by the way
in many situations like this where white
is offering this porn actually in many
situations black can take it it's just
risky in this position it's not risky
it's bad 95 Queen back and Bishop f4 and
he cannot really prevent 97 which will
win the exchange yeah so here this is
not a playable option at all okay
castles work t1 or kind of kind of
normal and night to be for this 195 are
the main
that before is putting some more control
over d5 Bishop g5 now and black is quick
and trying to get the bishop pair yeah
white now is taking if white goes back
um black we probably played Bishop d7
and it tends to put the bishop on c6
yeah here again we see why this a form
is a useful move from black yonder
Knight is sitting very nice long before
this is an interesting alternative
though foot wide he took however and the
idea is that after the capture wine is
increasing his control over the d5
square so that d4 d5 becomes a far more
likely option first however why this
activating his knights 94 b6 have to
develop that c8 bishop somehow and 95
yeah now an interesting hoof by West
Villa it's not a novelty he plays the
move Bishop h4 yes putting the bishop
out of away from that possibility of
being being captured in a recent game
between ye with white and the German now
we cannot con prodigy that's wrong when
we have a good junior player dennis VAR
clarissa may be 19 something like that
18 19 20 very young is close to 2600
yeah walking up late Bishop e7 here in
this in this position adapter look a 3
Bishop d7 and at the end it was a draw
against ye ye got a an attack but
Buckner defended this nicely but ok
swinger plays Bishop age home and after
g3 goes back to his seven one point is
he actually to provoke that g3 move
because rook a 32 g three can be n
very valid attacking option for wide so
this is actually a small accomplishment
that g3 had to be played I mean
accomplishment for black yeah
interesting is now Knight to c3 why does
going back why is it going back he wants
to play d5 rights advantage here on
advantage he's are better but white
strom cart is that d 45 opens up the
position quite quickly in a situation
where black is not developed fully yet
Bishop f6 was played yeah the more
natural move or more natural-looking
movers bishop to be several however
after that you always have to be on the
lookout for those sacrifices for example
after a five black has to be quite
careful if he takes now then night f7
Luke f7 3d6 is actually quite dangerous
for example after 28 Queen he wanders
the thread Queen takes several here why
does actually are not better I think
this is what mates vidim swidler and
yeah refrain from the move on Bishop d7
he played bishop to have six yeah and
now d 5 of course that breakthrough
Black now has to be very very careful if
he takes on d5 after 95 white already
wins and there is no good move now at
something like this is just a pretty
obvious disaster there is really only
that move the move that you play Queen
to see cell and now it gets rather sharp
yeah d 6 the default is pushing forward
into quincy 5 yeah a very sharp position
we have to mention that the clock times
are complete bogus yeah there is no
official relay here to those Ward's some
it's all has to be done by hand or
whatever I don't know how they do it but
they don't hear
I'm losing the ICC boards they don't get
a regular normal move relay move
transmission jutsu that legal
mumbo-jumbo that are gone has put up the
organizer of the match order of them of
the tournament so don't don't really
look at the clock times they don't make
any sense so d 625 lat 9416 bishop here
and then 94 also interesting and I think
that it probably is roughly equal but
it's very complicated and i'm not really
claiming that the time that I spent it
is enough to get a full picture here
something like this f 395 I think it
looks okay for black something like this
definitely dangerous but that pawn is
probably check it's probably something
that check black and keep a check here
in fact some kind of Perpetual shakers
happening yeah yeah it's it's difficult
for why to go out I mean you can but
after D for you don't really have a
clear move and this is now part of the
equation yum so that was an alternative
to seven but Nagi for it's not a bad
news yeah had to keep it I had to take
it I'm sorry and back to c6 yeah a deep
one is dangerous it really is but how
dangerous is it can you promote probably
not but it can definitely be very
irritating this should be three with
this idea yeah and it's quite
interesting black just place King aveda
prophylactically moving the King away
from the check on on age seven
yeah the next move by byla camera is
very natural a very natural
normal-looking move but it ultimately
doesn't um lead to much it seems that
here he should have played some more
yeah maybe modest continuation you could
call it something like this should be
true for example and the whole situation
remains complicated and very interesting
yeah interesting fighting position um
but Nakamura smooth looks totally normal
he goes to age 7 let's kind of move that
like everybody wants to play I get the
Queen Nia the King try to make something
happen however after h5 there is a
problem um this checho is just losing
stuff than I the same so the night has
to move away and now 95 and this is the
thing this diagonal is opened up and
there is this check thread and what now
if white goes back he really doesn't
have much to show for this Queen see
cygnus the thing what now threatening
mate yeah so Bishop e-force what was
played and now after this blackheads no
problem at all he can just take and play
rook a7 and now we see that the d7 point
is actually attacked three times so how
do you keep it the answer is pretty
pretty straightforward you don't it was
just as nice logic but energy for us
saving the day you just lose the pond
this is the thing um the only thing that
white has here is some activity and he I
think it does does a decent job of
keeping this activity going he took here
we are using that pin that also leads to
more simplification
takes check take him group d 4 and a 5
yeah black it's better there are a
couple of things going for him weak weak
yeah also with this and the black king
is already in the game while the white
king is on g1 the thing where I'm not
really satisfied now with what I'm
telling you is I cannot really tell you
if this should be a win or not um while
we were driving back from my team match
today and I discussed that with the
teammate of mine is also i am with
roughly roughly my rating way about an
equal equal strength and we weren't sure
if this is something that swidler should
win norm if it's still enough for a draw
now can we were pretty much and will
lose one of those pawns he will lose the
two points as in this happen that he
will lose the two parts for the one
point and that has to defend this with
one on down um with roofs and nights um
is that we know is set a draw as I said
we weren't sure I actually tend to think
that white probably with perfect play
should draw but I'm not sure at all I'm
really not one thing is clear with rooks
its draw and pretty dead draw rooks the
Knights definitely helps the side with
the porn because night endings upon up
offer very good winning chances so here
rook trade for example wouldn't be that
bad for black best however is to keep
both pieces on the wanna try to combine
the advance of the pawns with with
threats yeah for example I putting the
right over here or g4 looking at the
porn and so on yes Rita is also doing
that he's activating it pushes the pawns
him and goes up with a king yeah and
into
sting decision now by nakamura he's not
the kind of person who wants to defend
passively all the time you pushes g-form
and yeah very interesting very
interesting moment now this is a move
that I'm absolutely unsure if it's a
good defensive idea and all I actually
have my doubts if it's a good idea but
I'm as i said i'm not really sure um if
or how exactly blacks play should be
improved I'm going to spoil it I did a
little bit it will end in a draw so nice
here night a for checkin idea takes King
takes oops I'm sorry I was a hand was
the wrong button and politics also came
into consideration but there's a check
and if you go up check you blunder check
the house check so you have to go back
and then neither three this is probably
not a particularly great idea so King
takes activating the king is more
logical there are two pawns that black
can attack and this is a pretty nice
night it looks very good but we weren't
sure as I say we won't show them if that
should be a way no not and we also
didn't have particularly clear what I am
sure relatively sure of is that
hereafter not g2 if swidler um wants to
if there is some kind of improvement it
has to be here and because I think this
is a drop this ending the rook ending as
a draw maybe this is just 92 and
continue just yeah keep the material
distribution and try to make something
happen here as i said i'm not sure if a
black should win yeah i think that
probably with perfect play white should
draw it on it can easily be that someone
takes a lot more time or simply it's
more knowledgeable than I am
um and we'll show you how black can
grind this ending to win I am I would be
slightly slightly surprised if black can
win but in the game as I said it didn't
really come late father was this plate
and jam tonight eggs and we have a look
ending and this is a draw it's pretty
it's pretty clear yeah important move
here white can give this up temporarily
to regain the pawn and he's got no
problems whatsoever they're getting this
channel here they agree to a draw so a
narrow a narrow escape for Nakamura but
a very important one for his overall
prospects in the tournament if he would
have lost the game and there maybe were
very critical moments or not maybe there
were very critical moves in the if you
would have lost that game sticking or
then on minnows minus two is pretty much
out of the race for the for the first
place now it is just minus one it's a
bad start but it doesn't really mean
that he's out of the competition yeah
after the rest day he needs to maybe get
a winning inside or out of the next two
games and then he's back and back in the
race okay let's have a look at to pile
of a roni on this is the first white
game of the policy has played two black
sides of the balance of farm and scored
just one draw um this time is got white
and goes for see form yeah we got an
English opening a roni a place tonight
f6 and d5 here quite often he plays lots
of Queens gambit after d 4 + 93
surprisingly it doesn't play c-46 that
off here you quite often place like this
so the very classical approach with if I
g 3 by 2 part of the normal and most
ambitious move and now our own Ian goes
for Bishop before yes played some lines
in different lights but this is probably
his main weapon and this this 95 this is
a sharp line 95 white also can castle
this is a little bit more interesting
especially after you for when white
clothes night to H form this looks a bit
stranger night on the rim is dim but it
is a very concrete idea why does
intending to trade those nights and oops
and win their porn the second point is
of course that this Bishop is under yeah
can be taken and so white gains the
bishop pan yeah d six-member ironia the
most usual logical move I'm starting to
develop the bishop p.m. the white chat
goes for this and tries to grab the pawn
rook e8 leads to a very very strong
conversation something like Bishop g2
vision g4 is even more than compensation
here White is losing his development is
just too bad so this is what type I
loved it it took the bishop and now has
the bishop am d3 and d5 yeah black is
some not avoiding opening the position
because he has to use as at the moment
good development um after d5 the move CD
525 in fact looks rather nice for black
note that why definitely cannot snatch
this pawn Jack it's after Luke 28 he has
no good news yeah this for example after
94 is already pretty awful so what he
played castles is the more ambitious
EG for by aronian i think a good move
you can also take on c4 but taking his
the probably probably even just a better
choice ya know white has an interesting
and interesting alternative here he took
on d3 with the Queen this leads to and
we can briefly look at when it leads to
maybe after 95 Black is winning this
pawn there was not a blunder that was a
was an intended pawn sacrifice white had
the alternative to play this they are
not sacrificing the pawn and here in
fact also it could be a pawn sacrifice
like this and this into the 927 wear
black will win this but why it has a
very decent play for that like this this
is this inter centralizing it's probably
never more than enough you know then
sometimes idea for the white queen to
enter in the night but it's probably
never more than enough compensation
event all it's it's tricky um the
sacrifice that Topalov goes for is
probably a little bit more aggressive
let's say and it's interesting he now
goes for 44 he's got the two bishops and
he's got a couple of open lines
available um yeah so II for Bishop e6
normal move and b3 note that e5 is not a
good idea due to c5 Queen cakes and 95
and this is totally ok for black he's
got a sound structure and upon it is a
bit of compensation but probably not
enough this is better I want to power
plants better be 398 we nee for went
back and now we come to the critical
position of the game really early but it
is the
critical position of the game and right
now probably had to take on d5 like it
takes and takes and we should be true
this is this leads to fairly unclear
positions where the white um bishops
both on keto positions um should give
some player for the poor like this this
black can even go all the way here that
probably forces group to be one looks a
bit awkward but it's not such a big deal
why its position here or compensation
what's compensation is what I have to
say is more of a long-term one here
anyway yeah he will just play here maybe
Bishop before just activating and quite
often this is enough for a pawn if you
have a bishop pair in a wide open
position it's quite often enough because
simply often the pressure is some
getting so substantial that the
defending side will feel that he
probably should return upon um however
this is not what what the part of played
he played the move rook to d1 and this
looks completely logical completely
normal but it has a technical problem
and again to Paolo is lacking a little
bit in sharpness and tactical play as he
did in the in the round the first round
when he lost to Ireland 1984 can be
played and Aronian played it what's the
idea after Bishop takes isn't that a pin
yeah it is but black has the move Queen
f6 and this is quite an embarrassing
moment the rukon a1 is hanging and the
bishop only four also has attacked here
um yeah blacks position is excellent
he's two pawns up and if he loses one
back let's say rook be one takes and
just say he would lose this which is not
so clear that he does but let's say he
loses now he actually will lose it right
like here here and white can take
the thing is black still has a pawn but
it also has the better position the
light squares in particular here are
very very weak black has a light squared
Bishop why doesn't very very good
position for black in the game and to
pile of tried bishop be true being two
pawns down but this is absolutely not
enough princy to f6 yeah ronan is very
relaxed about returning one corner if
white oops sorry against this pawn back
um everything is very comfortable for
black a can move the Queen he's got good
play on the light squares and upon yeah
here for example if the night could move
Bishop to the fact that would be
fantastic Bishop on a long diagonal
where this Bishop is binding on granite
yet the part of tries to keep more
pieces on the board I think we can go
ahead to a couple of moves important
moment g5 this is not weakening it's
just driving the night away to a worse
square and this is a very good square
for the noid f4 this is traded bishop
over here yeah black is consolidating on
the King side and now brings the the
night over here yeah a good job by
Aronian he just has two pawns it's just
what it is um rookie seven now the move
94 probably was a little bit more
precise like this this and going here
but this is a slightly computer ish
approach it's it's not bad of course but
yogi 7 is a good human move nothing
nothing wrong with that what kind of
sound was that no idea um yeah that is a
good I think human move takes Queen
takes and now queen age 54 supply
after Queen h5 the game is essentially
over and 25 was a bit tougher even
though it probably won't help at the end
and group d 8 and Queenie for and rook
d4 is a good move we are forcing the
issue it first looks like this isn't
that great because white is getting a
pawn back here but after this this check
this right now at the end has to take
care about this so we have to go back
and ruby three and this is actually even
worse than it looks that position is
completely lost them that porn is is
gone and the black Bishop is so far
better than the white knight that this
win will become very easy um still Queen
h5 was played and now chapter this black
gets a fantastic night and now closes
down any activity for the white Bishop
the next moves were not very difficult
for Aronian I guess yeah open up a G
file the night was supported him yeah
now only one thing has to fight 27 going
for 25 and after king here check check
and 25 now kepala preside the big
problem is that this and this is a maid
thread in two and white it has no
defense to that there's always that that
square on g2 for the mate so the second
loss here for the parlor and pretty
drastic one and he sacrificed upon early
on if we look at the start of the game
here with this with this and that was
still I think kind of okay
but then I think he probably really just
blundered 90-84 because he maybe didn't
see Queen f6 I'm really not sure but
it's clear that this is not sufficient
compensation after night XD for aronian
took the pawn and later converted this
pretty convincingly so aronian now in
the lead as well weather plus one score
the other players on a plus one arnaud
and kayaking now he's joined bomb by the
median number 12 part of whatever is on
a minus 2's go after three rounds and
almost out of contention I think if you
lose two games you probably have to win
five or six to to compensate at the end
there will be a plus 30 plus 4 score
necessary and the way to pile of plate
up to here would be very surprising to
see him win five or six game it's games
it's it's super difficult anyway and
especially after that start it doesn't
really seem very very likely okay this
was coverage of round three of the
candidates tournament held in moscow i
hope you enjoyed it tomorrow monday the
14th there will be no round as rest day
so it will continue on the tuesday and
yeah again i will make a video for round
form on that tuesday probably ok thanks
for watching bye bye